OK, now, one other thing.
I want to separate this clip out from yesterday's
press briefing, because it really boggles
the mind how ignorant and clueless Donald
Trump still is on the basics of Corona virus
during yesterday's press briefing.
Donald Trump asked, is there a way to separate
the flu and corona virus?
Can we distinguish if someone has the flu
from someone who has corona virus?
It's almost like Trump hasn't spent the last
six months talking about testing Corona virus
testing corona virus tests, which tell you
whether you have corona virus or not.
This is inconceivable that this is a question
we're still getting from Trump in September.
You see what's happening in Europe.
However, they have a very big spike.
Countries that we thought we're doing well
aren't doing well.
They had some very big spikes, very, very
big surge.
Months ago, we increased our nation's procurement
of the flu vaccine by 66 percent.
And we ask Americans to go get their annual
flu shot as early as possible.
It's possible, I would imagine, Scott, that
the flu can get mixed up with the virus and
people can they get the virus when actually
it's another flu season coming on?
I don't know.
It's.
I hope they can keep them separate.
Can they keep them separate?
We hope so.
They will.
It's going to be a very interesting time.
But we have a flu season coming up.
We've had some flu seasons, which are really
massive over the years.
Scott, do we have a way of separating a flu
case and a corona virus case?
And even more bizarre.
I mean, it's a Gong Show.
Scott Atlus bizarrely says, I hope we do.
And Donald Trump says, I don't think we do.
He's spent the last six to seven months talking
about Corona virus tests, testing how many
tests, how fast are the tests?
He says it all the time.
When you test, you find cases.
That's how you separate a corona virus case
from something else.
We have a test for the flu, which tells us
if someone has the flu.
We have a test for corona virus, which tells
us if someone has corona virus.
How does the president of the United States
not know that at this point?
It it's a mind blowing, inconceivable ignorance
and and maybe more import.
Well, not more importantly, but equally interesting
is that this is probably a peek behind the
curtain of how people deal with Trump behind
the scenes.
The normal response, if someone says, hey,
can we tell the difference between corona
virus and the flu?
A normal response would be absolutely.
We have tests for the flu and we have test
for corona virus.
No problem.
This is how it works.
Scott Atlas instead says, I hope that we can
wait.
And my sense is that this is how it works
behind the scenes.
Frequently we wonder Trump spin mispronouncing
convalescent plasma as convalescent plasma
for months.
How is no one just said, you know Mr. Pratt,
sir.
As Trump likes to say, sir, it's plasma.
Apparently, Trump loses his mind when people
do that.
We wonder why does Trump keep saying the 1917
flu?
It's the 1918 flu.
Why has no one gone up to him and said it's
1918, not 1917?
Well, Scott Atlas's response tells us why
people are either afraid of Trump or they've
decided they can't correct him or it's pointless
to correct him or whatever.
But that is probably the explanation that
you saw there.
It and it's scary because there is no error
correcting mechanism in the same way that
Scott Atlas doesn't just say, yes, of course,
we have flu tests and coronavirus tests.
We have to believe that behind the scenes
you see a similar lack of pushback on foreign
policy, on economic policy, on everything.
Horrifying, horrifying
and frightening.